et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
hervé morin bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous prédisons de
l'install installez vous je vous en prie
et président de la région normandie
président du mouvement el les centristes
on a beaucoup de l'actualité à voir avec
vous avez morin mais d'abord c'est en
tant qu'ancien ministre de la défense
que je voudrais vous interroger sur ce
qui se passe au mali la tension est très
vive entre la france et le mali et jean
castex au sénat a dit qu'il y avait une
très grande crise politique nos soldats
français sont sur place est-ce qu'il
faut quitter le mali
très clairement toutes choses étant
égales par ailleurs 20 bien entendu on
n'est pas le même contexte c'est pas la
même situation mais on a un schéma qui
s'approche malheureusement chaque jour
de plus en plus de celui qu'on a connu
en afghanistan
on est arrivé pour lutter contre le
djihadisme
au mali avec l'idée d'avoir un accord
politique de reconstruire un état
et aujourd'hui on apparaît de plus en
plus comme une force d'occupation c'est
ça le schéma qui est malheureusement
toujours le même puisque
le but de guerre en quelque sorte le but
de notre intervention militaire a échoué
on a une junte
on a aujourd'hui de plus en plus de
difficultés à bâtir un accord politique
dans la région et donc au bout du compte
quelle autre solution avons-nous que
celle de considérer que nous devons nous
retirer
le calme alternant ne nous faisons pas
d'illusions mais quels que soient les
moyens qui ont été déployés qui sont
énormes l'effort de la france est
gigantesque un plus de 5000 hommes c'est
rien pour la france il ya les la force
la minustah etc bref il ya
au bout du compte un espace qui est
gigantesque avec un accroissement des
forces terroristes chaque année et donc
au bout du compte l'équation elle est
impossible parce qu'on est sur des des
guerres asymétriques
entre la puissance militaire des forces
occidentales pour faire simple et de
l'autre du terrorisme du harcèlement de
l'attentât est donc en clair dans ce
dans ce dialogue là nous sommes en
général en difficulté comme nous l'avons
été brillante
d'où pour moi l'idée que barkan doit
être revu de fond en comble est qu'il
nous faut probablement nous replier sur
le niger
bâtir un modèle dans lequel nous sommes
bien entendu encore en capacité
d'intervenir en cas en cas d'urgence
mais continuer à déployer des forces
importantes qu'en très clairement on n'a
pas réussi à construire un état de droit
ou tout du moins un semblant d'état
quand y'a pas d'accord politique avec
les forces du nord et c'est un retrait à
quelle échéance très rapide je pense
qu'il ya un moment il faut tirer des
conclusions et donc d'aider maintenant
il faut commencer à se replier ou mais
re
commencer par ce que seront nos replis
pas 5000 hommes comme ça du jour au
lendemain on va essayer il faut faire ça
dignement proprement il faut se donner
les moyens de pouvoir rapatrier nos
moyens tout ça ces deux sont des
opérations très lourde quand la jante
manen explique l'ambassadeur de france
aux qualifs c'est ça comment bras très
clairement de d'une rupture appelons ça
comme ça mais plus non mais moi ça fait
longtemps que je dise humiliation vous
vous pour chercher des mots ce que je
sais ce que je veux dire c'est que ça
fait très longtemps je dis que de toute
façon ne tiendra pas parce que toute
façon l'espace est gigantesque et que
quels que soient les volumes d'hommes on
n'est pas en situation de de pouvoir
installer quelque chose de durable c'est
les conditions politiques ne sont pas
lui c'est tout on peut pas simplement
nous assurer la stabilité d'un pays dans
lequel personne ne veut neveu ne veulent
à bâtir cette stabilité l'autre sujet
qui concerne l'international c'est la
crise entre l'ukraine et la russie les
états unis ont annoncé le déploiement de
3000 militaires en soutien à l'otan en
europe est ce que vous craignez une
escalade dans ce conflit jusqu'où ça
près je suis comme vous je lis la presse
je n'ai pas plus d'informations que cela
bien sûr c'est très inquiétant c'est
très inquiétant
jusqu'où la russie va aller jusqu'au
bout et il ira dans sa volonté de de
fall en dise et l'ukraine puisque c'est
de cela dont il s'agit
fall on disait au sens de la période de
l'union soviétique on est bien d'accord
donc vous voyez un risque d'invasion
sens et rien de ce que je vois c'est
qu'ils ont il ya semblait si j'en crois
ce que dit la presse ce que dit le miz
affaires étrangères est à cent mille
hommes qui sont là donc vous vous dites
qu'ils sont pas là pour rien en même
temps c'est un seul e
l'invasion de l'ukraine serait un acte
extrêmement grave impliquant au bas mot
des sanctions des sanctions très dures
que nous serions obligés de mettre en
oeuvre on l'a déjà annoncé
économique financière enfin peut tout
imaginer et ensuite quel est le niveau
de réaction militaire des américains
imaginent que tout cela a été évoqué
entre chefs d'état
une solution diplomatique
mais il faut toujours dialoguer et
jusqu'au dernier moment il faut chercher
à construire le dialogue dû construire
le dialogue et vladimir poutine c'est
pas facile et donc il faut pas y aller
si si au bout du compte c'est pour se
prendre une bonne humiliation pour
reprendre le vocable qui est tout à
l'heure voilà donc et puis par ailleurs
vous savez
les etats-unis
considèrent que bien souvent en europe
il ya plutôt un esprit de démission donc
ils feront d'abord comme ils l'entendent
même s'ils le feront bien sûr dans un
cadre qui sera celui du dialogue de
l'alliance atlantique
cette fois c'est là qu'ils se trouvaient
hier il a parlé d'immigration puisqu'il
à la présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne une plaide pour une
réforme de schengen il dit que la
promesse de libre circulation en europe
a été mise à mal par le terrorisme par
la vague migratoire par la crise
sanitaire est ce que pour vous il faut
réformer schengen est ce qu'il va y
arriver on a l'impression de vous
entendre mais recettes non il n'y
arrivera pas on voit bien tout ça c'est
une posture de campagne en fait il se
sert de l'union européenne pour faire
pour adresser des messages à nos
compatriotes dans le cadre de sa
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
c'est aussi simple que ça et d'ailleurs
s'il avait été
il aurait dû proposer à l'union
européenne d'attendre pour que la france
prenne la présidence de l'union le faire
maintenant en sachant qu éventuellement
dans ce que j'espère dans soixante dix
jours on aura aux 80 jours on aura un
autre présent la république ça veut dire
que la présence française sur une crue
ans pour rien on sait pas dire qu'on
vous il ne fera rien durant cette
présidence est uniquement là pour
envoyer des messages vous voyez bien que
c'est un cetain que le lui que que sept
entre le discours au parlement européen
qui a été vécu par tous les membres de
l'union européenne tous les
parlementaires européens comme un débat
franco français est très mal appréciée
au sein de l'europe désormais à présent
la république qui s'adresse sur chaque
sujet avec en arrière pensée le débat
national ça peut pas servir à la cause
de la construction européenne donc c'est
une présidence qui ne sera qui sera une
présence pour rien et d'ailleurs quand
vous allez à bruxelles tout le monde le
pense moi j'y étais il ya deux ou trois
mois tout le monde se demandait comment
on allait pouvoir avancer sur des
dossiers quand sur certains dossiers il
faut du courage et que le risque c'est
qu'il y est un retentissement qui soient
négatifs au niveau national et que de
l'autre on en fasse une tribune bas on
exactement mon schéma
qui électoralement parlant vous on a
écouté il est comme il sait que s'il y a
bien deux sujets sur lesquels les
français sont extrêmement critiques sur
son bilan c'est la question c'est au
tour de l'environnement et c'est sur les
questions régaliennes et donc il essaie
en quelque sorte de de se bâtir une
autre
voilà deux d'apparaître comme quelqu'un
qui veut faire bouger les choses quand
on n'a jamais eu aussi peu d'obligation
de quitter le territoire national mise
en oeuvre et on va continuer à parler du
reste de l'actualité on va accueillir
guilhem reykjavik qui nous a rejoint ça
y est on l'a retrouvé depuis marseille
guilhem des rédactions du journal la
provence n'est pas nous envoyer un petit
peu de soleil s'il vous plaît parce que
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
on va parler d'eux
on va parler avec vous de la question
des étals hervé morin guilhem je vous
laisse la parole donc dans quelques
instants les ehpad dont notamment le
groupe orpea mis en cause pour des
soupçons de maltraitance sur les
personnes âgées dans c est parce que le
groupe des monts son pdg l'a redit hier
est-ce que vous avez des ronds t de cas
de maltraitance dans votre région
d'abord non franchement je n'en ai pas
ce qui est sûr c'est que
pour malheureusement connaître
pour connaître
beaucoup d pad on a il ya un immense
effort que la france doit effectuer pour
les remettre à niveau
clairement et avec du personnel qui
souvent est en grande tension
insuffisance d'effectifs
des niveaux de rémunération qui sont
faibles c'est très dur ce métier c'est
très dur et en plus quand on voit en
normandie un certain nombre de débats
d'il ya un immense besoin
d'investissements ça fait aucun doute
alors après la situation de sous groupes
privés honnêtement je comme vous
une remise en cause
de
tout ça il ya quand même déjà les
familles qui sont là qui sont capables
d'être des lanceurs d'alerté il a une
question mathieu
oui tout à fait moi je suis dans une
région ici la région sud où ouzou 11% de
la population à plus de 75 ans et plus
que la moyenne nationale 1 qui autour de
2,9 pour ça on voit bien que la question
de la dépendance des personnes âgées va
être un vrai sujet dans la décennie à
venir on fait quoi justement pour
permettre aux gens de terminer leur vie
leurs derniers jours dans les meilleures
conditions c'est quoi le programme sur
la question
voilà la question elle est assez simple
comme j'ai dit il faut à la fois mieux
rémunérés celles et ceux qui travaillent
dans ces établissements est d'ailleurs
dans ces conditions je vous rappelle que
valérie pécresse est celle qui défend le
pouvoir d'achat et donc ça se redressera
aussi assez assez personne puisque nous
avons décidé d'augmenter de 10% la
rémunération
jusqu'à deux ans et demi smic par une
baisse des cotisations sociales
parce que nous avons décidé aussi je le
rappelle de défiscaliser et de
d'exonérer de charges les heures
supplémentaires parce que nous avons
décidé aussi défiscaliser d'exonérer de
charges le rachat des jours de rtt donc
il ya un vrai volant un pouvoir d'achat
dont pourront profiter ses personnels il
ya probablement un effort à faire en
matière de formation il semble
clairement et puis de l'autre il ya un
immense besoin d'investissements comme
je voyais vous parliez des départements
tout à l'heure c'est investissements il
doit notamment être porté par les
départements qui ont des responsabilités
ce qui impose aussi d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour vous le dire monsieur qui
est une vraie loi de décentralisation ou
enfin y ait une clarification des
compétences on est dans des domaines où
l'état a attribué une partie des
compétences aux départements sans les
attributs et complètement ce qui fait
qu'on est dans le mélange des gens qui
créent bien sûr des situations
d'irresponsabilité moi je suis pour une
idée simple c'est que d'ailleurs c'est
pas la mienne c'est aussi celle de
valérie pécresse sait que
le chant du médico social soit
totalement transférées aux départements
que ce soit les départements qui lé
budget les financements et la l'autorité
et la décision sûrement chambre du champ
médico-social on va parler
cette campagne on va parler de ce que
dit ce matin dz bank dans le parisien
alors elle annonce qu'il ya 718 mille
contrats d'apprentissage ont été signés
l'an dernier c'est un record absolu dit
elle elle dit que les mesures du
gouvernement durant ce quinquennat ont
permis de ramener le taux de chômage des
jeunes au plus bas depuis 2008
finalement ils ont mené une bonne
politique là dessus sur l'apprentissage
il faut il faut se méfier il ya en effet
plus d'apprentis il ya plus d'apprentis
parce que
l'apprentissage notamment sur la
première année ne coûte plus rien
il y a plus d'apprentis aussi parce que
clairement eu et honnêtement je dis
royer j'ai beau être dans l'opposition
je pense que certains ont critiqué cette
idée que globalement la tissage coûté
très peu sur les premières années
la première année
moi je préfère des gens qui soit en
apprentissage des jeunes qui souhaitent
en apprentissage plutôt que des jeunes
qui sont dans les missions locales je
pense que le coût global pour la
collectivité est probablement moins
élevé ce qu'elle oublie de dire dans
tout cela c'est que l'apprentissage
augmente peu
sur les niveaux infra bac et qu'il
augmente beaucoup sur l'enseignement
supérieur
premier point ça elle ne le dit pas
c'est qu'en vérité les chiffres sont
beaucoup plus faibles par ailleurs au
même moment que les contrats
d'apprentissage se sont développées les
contrats de professionnalisation se sont
effondrés quand on parle d'alternance il
faut parler du tout et troisième point
ce qu'elle ne dit pas c'est que tout ça
s'est fait dans un contexte d'explosion
complète des coûts des coûts puisque
france compétences qui finance les coups
contre alors c'est un peu technique tout
ça je suis désolé
se retrouve avec des déficits de
plusieurs milliards d'euros je crois de
mémoire c'est entre 4 et 5 milliards
d'euros donc en clair comme on avait
peur que cette réforme de
l'apprentissage échoue on à financer
massivement des centres de formation qui
ont alors améliorer leur compte de façon
extraordinaire mais au point aujourd'hui
tient déficit pour le contribuable de 4
à 5 milliards ce qui veut dire quoi
c'est que bien entendu et elle le dit
dans son article je l' ai parcouru très
rapidement dans la voiture en venant
c'est que les coûts contrat c'est-à-dire
le financement de l'apprentissage dans
les centres de formation va être revue à
la baisse à et prochaine donc après
avoir connu globalement la générosité
appartient et prochaine les choses vont
changer et deuxièmement ce qu'elle ne
dit pas c'est que quand on a des
déficits paraît il va falloir les payer
qui va les payer les entreprises parce
que sont les branches qui vont payer au
bout du compte donc
oui les chiffres sont se sont améliorées
ils sont épaulés il faut les regarder
précisément et c'est surtout
l'enseignement supérieur qui en a
bénéficié
et troisièmement c'est un coût
gigantesque à venir pour les branches
professionnelles à moi sur le pouvoir
d'achat parce que c'est évidemment
important la mesure phare de valérie
pécresse était cette hausse berne est de
10% alors là elle revient petit même si
elle dit que ce n'est pas un recul mais
c'est plutôt je suis l'ami fabrication
c'est parce que quand même le message
envoyé est mauvaise qu'elle donne pas
l'impression qu'elle est en train de
céder au patronat et messi absolument
barreau recul je trouve que la
présentation qui en a été fait j'ai eu
l'occasion de l'évoquer ça avec un son
de vos confrères c'est pas un recul
c'est simplement l'expliqué simplement
la construction de la méthode ok elle
dit je veux une augmentation de 10% des
salaires très bien
pourquoi elle le veut parce que vous
voyez bien que vous pouvez pas
constamment expliqué qu'on a des
problèmes de recrutement massif et qu'en
même temps on crée pas les conditions
d'une vraie différence entre les revenus
de solidarité et des revenus du travail
premier point deuxièmement qui peut
aujourd'hui contester le fait que vivre
avec 1200 1300 euros par mois c'est
extrêmement difficile bon à partir de là
elle dit voilà j'entends le message du
patronat en disant je vous explique la
méthode on va baisser les cotisations
sociales donc immédiatement il y aura 3
% et ensuite on a une conférence sociale
un observatoire des salaires et ont
construit ensemble les moyens pour
aboutir à cette hausse des salaires de
10% mais on est bien sûr d'en voir la
couleur du coup des 10 et bien sûr aussi
le patronat elvis juin mais non pas du
tout elle dit je le ferai et on verra
ensemble parce que quelle sera la baisse
d'impôts de production où il faut mettre
le curseur je vous explique irène la
simplification qu'on luttera contre la
bureaucratie qu'on permettra aux
entreprises de créer plus de valeur
ajoutée et bien nous chiffrons tout cela
nous chiffrons notre pôle et les
conséquences politiques économiques sur
la création de valeur dans le pays et à
partir de là on construit le cheminement
mais soyez certain d'une chose c'est que
la hausse des salaires de 10% elle sera
mise en oeuvre par ce qu'elle veut aussi
simplement que cela et guilhem à une
question nation
oui moi j'ai une question sur la
conjoncture économique parce qu'on voit
bien que le chômage est plutôt à un
niveau assez bas en ce moment on voit
bien que la croissance
7 pour cent et quelque chose de
d'historique en savez plus de 50 ans que
ce n'était pas arrivé en france sur ce
thème de l'économie vous êtes vous
conseiller économique de valérie
pécresse vous allez avoir du mal a
martelé sur le terrain à un autre
discours parce que le bilan pour le
moment nicolas denis colada d'emmanuel
mc ren est plutôt bon nicolas sakozy cdh
et avant si c'était de lui dont vous
vouliez parler
écoutez il faut quand même regarder les
choses avec un peu plus de d'objectivité
que cela un ça n'est qu'un rattrapage en
a simplement retrouver le pib qui était
le nôtre mans la crise c'est tout bon
deuxièmement c'est un c'est une
croissance qui est alimenté par la dette
c'est de la création de masse monétaire
bon voilà c'est aussi simple que ça donc
les fondamentaux de l'économie française
et notamment le potentiel de croissance
de l'économie française reste
extrêmement faible troisièmement si vous
regardez les choses vous avez tout de
même toute une série d'indicateurs et
jean nohain cite qu'un seul pour éviter
de de dassault mais les gens et des
chiffres c'est la balance commerciale on
nous explique que la compétitivité de
l'économie française s'est redressée
parlons de vous le dire si la
compétitivité de l'économie française
s'est redressée la balance commerciale
on a dû se redresser au relax balance
commerciale continue à se dégrader elle
ne se dégradent pas avec la chine elle
se dégrade avec l'union européenne
à part le royaume-uni avec lesquels on a
toujours eu un excédent
important et un ou deux pays dont la
grèce et je ne suis plus qu'à loupé du
sud nous avons des déficits commerciaux
massifs notamment avec l'allemagne et
ses déficits il ne se réduisent pas ce
qui montre très clairement que la
compétitivité de l'économie française
est loin d'avoir retrouvé un chemin un
chemin favorable il ya eu des mesures de
prises qu'on était des mesures que
j'approuve comme par exemple
le
certaines mesures sur la fiscalité
notamment sur la flat tax sur le sur les
revenus du capital ok mais derrière ça
il y a des chemins considérable il ya
notamment monsieur toute la question de
la politique énergétique ou là disons
clairement les choses on a un échec
gigantesque emmanuel macron me lisent
l'économie des finances de françois
hollande secrétaire général adjoint de
l'elysée en charge des textures économie
donc sur les cinq années hollande il en
a une part de responsabilité
puis ces cinq années de mandat il a
affaibli de façon gigantesque la filière
électronucléaire française qui est
absolument indispensable pour lutter
contre la décarbonation qui est
absolument indispensable pour permettre
à l'économie française d'avoir une
énergie peu cher et qui est absolument
indispensable compte tenu des besoins
considérables en électricité puisqu'on
sait qu'on va avoir un doublement des
consommations d'électricité et bien
monsieur la seule mesure de monsieur
macron sur le sujet c'est là un vrai
scandale c'est la fermeture de
fessenheim et avec une centrale à
charbon à 20 minutes ou annie wayne de
mes requêtes en allemagne très bien
voilà et ce qui nous amène aujourd'hui à
importer de l'électricité carbonée des
pays d'europe
alors que nous avions une filière
nucléaire capable de répondre à la
question de la décarbonation et qui nous
permet d'ailleurs de pouvoir relancer
une politique industrielle parce que
quand vous bâtissez des centrales
nucléaires vous porter aussi le la
filière industrielle française est
justement guilhem une question sur le
nucléaire
oui parce qu'on parle d'eux on parle de
nucléaire on parle effectivement de la
flambée des prix de l'énergie électrique
en ce moment vous dites que emmanuel
macron a sa part de responsabilité dans
le sujet mais est-ce que c'est plutôt
l'europe qui a sa part de responsabilité
est ce que c'est pas plutôt l'europe qui
en 1996 en libéralisant ce marché en
créant une règle une clé de répartition
un petit peu particulière aujourd'hui
créer le contexte qui fait qu edf est
obligé de de vendre moins cher de
l'électricité qui lui coûte très cher à
produire
c'est pire que ça c'est qu'elle fournit
de l'électricité à des concurrents qui
eux mêmes
le modèle européen pour que nouveaux
auditeurs comprennent c'était de dire on
va sortir des monopoles et on va
permettre à des fournisseurs devaient
rentrer en concurrence et % mal an on va
obliger les les producteurs historiques
de fournir une partie de l'électricité à
un prix qui n'a jamais bougé il reste
elle-même 42 euros
sauf que ses fournisseurs
ne se sont jamais lancé dans la
production peut dire sont claires on est
dans un modèle qui ne marche pas parce
que vous avez des gens et qui vous
fournissez d'électricité peu cher et qui
devient ensuite les concurrents d'edf et
puis quand ça va mal ou vous l'avez vu
qu'ils se qui se tient les flux de vous
avez vu michel edouard leclerc il a plus
de facilité avant de sa vague est pas
cher que de continuer à tenir ces
contrats sur l'électricité bien
en vérité j'ai discuté de ça vous voyez
avec les représentants des grands fonds
d'investissement français ils disent une
chose simple ce sont des tels niveaux de
capex d'investissement que les centrales
nucléaires ou que la production
d'énergie massive qu'on ne peut pas
considérer c'est le prix du marché
notamment le prix du marché marginal qui
va permettre aux investisseurs de
construire quand on est sur des marchés
à 50 ou 60 ans d'investissement il faut
qu'ils aient un système public et un
système de régulation qui soient mises
en oeuvre et donc il faut refonder et
reconstruire cette histoire est un
dernier mot rapidement un terrain parce
que le temps file il y aura un grand
meeting de valérie pécresse j'espère
vous y serez on suivra tout ça bien
ensuite tous les meetings au zénith dans
dix jours est-ce que c'est un moyen pour
elle de relancer une campagne qui patine
goûter la campagne
bon on est valérie un vrai socle à la
rassembler toute la famille on est tous
ensemble
elle a fait énormément de propositions
moi je vois une candidate hyper sérieuse
travailleuse chaque proposition fait
l'objet d'un vrai travail de fond qui
stagne attendant les laisser d'accord
mais et mais excusez moi de vous dire
pour l'instant la campagne à l'it dans
une espèce de faux plats lier un seul
élément c'est y en a un qui continuent à
faire campagne avec les moyens de l'état
et qui dit qu'il n'est pas candidat donc
attendons qu'ils que monsieur macron
puisse annonce sa candidature et la
campagne va repartir sur un autre élan
et on vous vers servez-vous d'avoir été
notre invité
[Musique]